good morning it gets Tuesday don't vlog
while biking we got canals too so I hate
the great nation of Canada recently
decided to discontinue its penny because
it doesn't facilitate commerce and also
it cost 1.5 Canadian cents to make a
penny but Hank here in America we're
keeping our pennies and that makes sense
because our pennies also don't
facilitate commerce and they cost two
point one cents to make
god I hate pennies now I call admit to
the pennies are relatively minor in
efficiency but today I want to talk
about three much more dramatic and
important examples of how our terrible
political discourse is leading to awful
policymaking but first I'm going to go
right over to the park okay so first the
Federal Aviation Administration which is
responsible for air traffic control and
safety inspections in that kind of thing
the FAA is mostly funded by a tax on
airplane tickets which like most
frequent fliers I am happy to pay
because my favorite kind of air traffic
is controlled air traffic and my
favorite kind of landing is not crash
but the last five years have seen 23
short term extensions of this tax mostly
because Congress has been fighting about
unions because fighting over unions
helps them raise money
each of these short term extensions
hurts the economy because if you're
building say a new air traffic control
tower it's much cheaper to do it with a
long term contract than with a gajillion
short term contracts same reason your
phone is cheaper if you sign a two-year
contract versus a one-year contract
right so that's a terribly inefficient
way of doing business but it's not the
crazy thing the crazy thing is that over
the summer Congress completely let the
FAA is funding lapse so they couldn't
collect that tax on every ticket now
you're probably thinking this wasn't so
bad after all the money just went into
the hands of the people who were buying
the tickets no it didn't it went into
the hands of the airlines because they
raised their prices the exact amount of
the DAX out of a giant Swan of a car
look it's a plane the only reason you're
safe is because of the FAA it needs our
funding
anyway Congress finally passed a
long-term budget in February but by then
this whole brouhaha probably cost us a
billion dollars example to the highway
bill so we've been doing the same thing
of these hugely inefficient short-term
extensions when it comes to our highway
funding but interestingly in this case
no one's fighting about unions so even
though everyone agrees that long-term
funding deals are cheaper and more
efficient we can't pass any long-term
funding deals because they involve big
numbers many Republicans backed by the
tea party don't want to vote for any
long-term bill because it would involve
a big number and they're opposed to big
government spending and so there's a
political liability in voting for say a
250 billion dollar highway bill so
instead we're going to vote for ten
thirty billion dollar highway bills
right so at this point a lot of
conservative nerdfighters probably think
that I'm this like big pink oh
Communists I'm not issue three Medicare
a fantastic and very popular government
program in which we give medics err no
way we give health care to old people
so everyone agreed that Medicare is
totally unsustainable by 2020 Medicare
could account for five percent of our
gross domestic product which is just
insane and Republicans have proposed
some interesting reform ideas for
Medicare but Democrats refused to
entertain them because of course that
would mean hurting our seniors by
cutting Medicare and those very same
seniors tend to vote for Democrats and
it makes sense because we all know that
spending more money to take care of our
seniors leads to healthier happier
seniors and we all want that because
when they're not happy they're very
cranky so it makes sense not to reform
Medicare except it doesn't because
insanely the states that spend the least
per Medicare patient get the best health
care outcomes this is largely for boring
reasons like preventive medicine and
washing your hands and not leaving
scalpels inside of people but it works
so we could totally use this data to
reform Medicare and control costs but
instead we won't
we'll just keep disagreeing with each
other for the sake of disagreeing
because yelling at each other is worth
more political points than sensible
compromise and our government will
continue to inhibit economic growth
while also minting pennies
god I hate pennies alright I could try
it in videos on a happy note so here's a
turtle I'll see you on Friday